che bello fare questi video sono
contento compreso landi di fare questi
video così quando mi gira il cazzo e va
bene allora facciamoci girare il cazzo
ed attenti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
nuovo video così questo è già un bel
video
allora ragazzi miei oggi vi racconto chi
mi ha fatto girare oggi i [ __ ]
l'ultima volta che ho fatto video del
genere parlavano il fatto che quando non
dicevo la intro certa gente si tagliava
le vene perché non dicevo la lindt viola
entro quale ho fatto sono a posto
passiamo al prossimo giramento di palle
il prossimo giramento di palle evito
vietato ai minori di 18 anni
su youtube non sapete di che cosa sto
parlando
vi spiego meglio noi youtubers sa che
quando carica video non deve caricare
contenuti sessualmente esplicito vero
non deve caricare video di nudo video di
gente che si spogli insomma cose che non
vanno caricate su youtube è fin qua
quando carichi un video e video può
essere libero ovvero non contiene niente
di sessualmente esplicito quindi lo
possono vedere tutti e fin qua bloccato
ovvero il video contiene contenuti
espliciti sessualmente quindi è bloccato
proprio c'è nessuno lo può vedere viene
anche tolto e fin qua e infine ragazzi
c'è una terza opzione che sta nel mezzo
dove il video è limitato significa che
quel video può essere visualizzato
soltanto da chi ha più di 18 anni e fin
qua non fa una piega e il proprio cazzo
sta il problema di oggi stamattina
ragazzi ho messo un video come tutte le
mattine i video in questione è mio padre
mi scopre mentre puntini puntini puntini
di che ciò che si è trattato ragazzi si
tratta di un videogame dove tu guardi
delle immagini sexy
attenzione non porno non con le tette di
fuori o sexy ci sono ragazze vestite
cioè sono immagini sexy non c'è niente
di vietato ai 18 anni se non è un porno
sono immagini normalissima anche perché
non necessitano neanche di censura alle
volte tipo in out lane tipico la
matranga de fori e io glielo censurato
ovviamente ma non c'è stato neanche
bisogno di censura perché gente distinta
titolo mio padre mi scopre mentre
puntini puntini puntini
la copertina è questa c'è il papa nel
videogioco che sarebbe questo è la tipa
di sfondo che non è nuda ho messo il
papa ha davanti perché ci stava il papa
però la tipa non c'è l'immagine c'è nel
gioco non è nuda la tizia ora youtube
quando ha visto questa copertina si è
allarmato della serie ha detto questo
video potrebbe contenere contenuti
sessualmente esplicite e allora che cosa
dovrebbe fare youtube youtube dovrebbe
aprire il video guardare il video
verificare se ci sono contenuti
sessualmente espliciti e all'occorrenza
bloccare il video
secondo voi youtube ha fatto così ma
marco fugazi blocchiamo il video alla
cazzo di cane senza guardarlo solo
perché nella copertina poteva sembrare
alla luce ragazzi di tutto questo
bordello provate a indovinare qual è
stata la mia reaction dopo aver visto il
video vietate minori di 18 anni
video soggetto ai limiti di età
significa che questo video non lo
possono guardare i minori di 18 anni
ed eccoci che fa vj fece due fiducia
perché ci hai setti bambini a tag da sto
gazze eaters di sto birillo di minchia
comunque ragazzi io vi assicuro che nel
video non ci stava un cazzo di vietato
ai minori di 18 anni perché sennò
l'avrei ovviamente censurato tipo i tizi
di outlast come che aveva censurato
appunto nonostante questo youtube che
ovviamente non avrà guardato ma anche un
secondo del video perché la nonna stava
preparando la pasta asciutta e quindi
non aveva un tempo di guardare la
bloccato alla cazzo di minchia avviso
video soggetto limiti di età semmai
clicchiamo qui ci apre una pagina di
youtube dove ci spiega che con significa
con significano le norme della community
leggiamo rispetta la community di
youtube non pretendiamo il tipo di
rispetto riservato a suore anziani e
neurochirurghi desideriamo soltanto che
non venga fatto cattivo uso del sito
perché secondo me se faccio vedere sta
roba suore anziani e neurochirurghi non
si scandalizzano manco per il cazzo di
di buddha ma capisce magari sei tu che
non sai quali sono i limiti e questo
video andava bloccato va bene andiamo a
verificare conoscete cinnamon taschen
bene è uno youtube perché io seguo da
una vita e mezza e anche lui ha fatto il
video su basterebbe che sarebbe quel
video giocoli la copertina è questa qui
quindi c'è il papa ci sono le tette
quindi praticamente quasi come la mia è
il titolo è dead che schmidt epping
ovvero mio padre mi scopre mentre mi
stavo masturbando c'è lui l'ha scritto
io non l'ho scritto perché ho detto va
magari non è il massimo scrivere
masturbando con quindi messi i puntini
di sospensione perché magari su youtube
appariva scritta non era il ma io ci
penso a queste cose ma andate pure a
bloccare mio cazzo di video e non quello
degli altri ma è giusto che non sia
stato bloccato quello di ken perché non
c'è effettivamente un cazzo visto video
da da bloccare non ci sono contenuti non
ci sono tette di fuori però come hanno
giustamente deciso di bloccarlo ma fuori
che youtube e non si può sbagliare
troppo grosso sito che ci vai
facciamo un altro esempio sfida con
l'arco epica fa vj verso sani ma blog
amsterdam
sta molto sessualmente esplicita fatico
di youtube non ci sono mai andati perché
gli bruciava il culetto quindi quando
facevo delle riprese in giro facevo
attenzione a non riprendere cose perché
c'è il quartiere a luci rosse un po un
bordello un bordello né vero senza la
parola facciamo attenzione a non
riprendere cose che magari non potevano
essere messa in un video purtroppo e
dico purtroppo mi è scappata una roba al
minuto 3 23 del video ma c'è una bambola
gonfiabile sono andato a guardare nello
sfondo effettivamente c'è una bambola
gonfiabile con le poppe de fori e ho
mica son s.romano anche io non mi sono
accorto ovviamente il video non è
bloccato perché mi piace stava una in
copertina way that the forest in
copertina del video ci siamo io e sasha
che siamo molto sexy ma non è
sessualmente esplicito quindi
ricapitolando il video aveva una
copertina normalissima quindi non
sessualmente esplicita ma dentro il
video c'era un immagine di una con le
pompe dei fori ovviamente youtube che
non guarda mai mezzo video non l'ha
bloccato ma neanche minimamente ha
invece bloccato l'altro che non c'era un
cazzo dentro god fucking jobs io ci ho
poi magari ci sono altri esempi di video
che non sono stati bloccati che sono
molto più sessualmente espliciti di
quello che ho fatto oggi tipo vabbè ora
il punto non è tanto questo e che tanto
su youtube c'è roba chi li insulta che
si insultano
c'è chi lancia i cornetti c'è chi riceve
i cornetti c'è chi parla di youtube
perché sennò non farebbe 3
visualizzazioni in croce chi non parla
né youtubers enfap 3 visualizzazioni in
croce c'è un sacco di merda che che gira
la cazzo di cane le loro vanno a cagare
nu casa a me perché ho messo nella
copertina una tipa che si vede che
charles ma andate a cagare mi avevate
chiesto sta roba un tempo e che
praticamente su youtube è uscito fuori
che esistono dei contenuti che sono più
volgari di altri di conseguenza sono
meno monetizzabili ovvero i video che
nei quali 10 parolacce c'è semplicemente
dicendo cazzo
il video è monetizzato di meno cosa ne
pensi tuffa vj mi avevano chiesto questa
cosa irata io capisco che un'azienda un
brand non voglia che la sua pubblicità
finisca su dei video dove uno dice
cazzoni tre secondi o dove si vedono le
tette
lo capisco perché se tu sei un azienda
che vuoi sponsorizzare il tuo prodotto e
quindi tu fai la pasta la pasta di
contadina gennarina buona che non scuoce
mai è la vuoi pubblicizzare sotto i
video di che ne so fa vj che ogni tre
secondi dice cazzo minchia [ __ ] è un po
strano perché magari nella pubblicità in
televisione la pubblicità è tutta tipo
tassa del contadino generi mentre su
youtube c'è scritto pasta del contadino
gennarino e poi il video e par che
attrae a cazzo [ __ ] merda troy e zoccole
cia un senso effettivamente questa cosa
quindi sì ma no c'è un'altra motivazione
c'è il fatto che il sud dovrebbe
perlomeno dire i cambiamenti che sta
facendo e discuterne con gli utenti che
fanno video porca [ __ ] o detto porca
[ __ ] niente passa qua sotto
infatti che youtube quando prende delle
decisioni le prende e basta
non c'è un sito non c'è una newsletter
che mi mandano via mail con su scritto
guardate che il mese prossimo facciamo
questo cambiamento guardate che il mese
prossimo
togliamo le stelline per votare i video
e mettiamo i mi piace
guardate che il mese prossimo i video di
sto gran cazzo di minchia saranno tutti
rimossi perché ci sta in culo vorrete
che il mese prossimo la nonna fa e la
bagna cauda e quindi non posso vedere i
video per vedere se ci sono contenuti di
sesso quindi di blocco a prescindere non
è che youtube chi dice le cose quindi tu
agisce di conseguenza ai tempo di
preparati da youtube fa lui fa fa fa le
cose fa lecco come qui prof che se esco
con le verifiche che non hanno spiegato
un cazzo c'è un problema di fondo non
manca il dialogo ma anche i dialoghi una
cazzo di mail lo skate sei stronzo e
sarai stronzo nel prossimo mese almeno
lo so cazzo bello il problema ok questo
è il [ __ ] problema di youtube chiudo
la parentesi non ho mai fatto questi
discorsi in vita mia non ho mai parlato
di youtube di ste robe però mi ha preso
ultimamente che
questa maglia autoritaria che ciò
sicuramente son riuscito a far valere le
mie opinioni
grazie